hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
chapter eight of Aristotle's categories
is quite lengthy and he's engaging in
some very important analyses in terms of
a category that we translate typically
as quality he uses two terms for this
when he's listing off the categories he
calls the top one that's sort of the
neuter substantive you know sort of an
abstract conception and then poyo taste
is a particular quality or quality in
general but understanding something to
be a quality like the blackness of the
time the purpleness of the shirt the you
know flexibility of the hand the
hardness of the ring and so on and so
forth so when Aristotle first
characterizes quality he he talks in
terms that might make it seem as if what
we're looking at is primarily human
beings and in fact human beings are
really the paradigmatic example for most
of the qualities in his works he is
particularly interested in quality in
part because it has to do with moral
attributes as well as you know sort of
physical sensible attributes that we can
talk about
so he'll he'll characterize that this
isn't defining it but characterize it as
that by which people are called
such-and-such and the reason we say
people there or in this translation men
is because he's using a teen a sin in
the Greek which which is masculine and
but but the key thing here is he's
saying qualities I I say are those
things in accordance with kitane po a
poyo a something is called such-and-such
something is said to have a certain
property or to have a certain quality in
any of these forms that we're gonna look
at in just a moment now this covers a
very very wide range so then we can talk
about the book having qualities like for
example being green
you know there's certain of these things
that we can't say that the book actually
hasn't the book doesn't have a habit or
a disposition but the book does have
certain natural capacities passive
qualities and figure and form alright we
can say that the book is rectangular for
example or that it composes well we can
say that it runs book shape you can
predicated that of it now that would be
its substance but then when you say okay
book now we say hardcover book right or
clothbound book or book in the Loeb
library series or any of these sorts of
things we are qualifying it we're saying
what kind of thing it is what attributes
it has not in terms of its essence or
its substance itself but in terms of all
the other things that we want to say
about it
and some of those are extremely
important this is not something that
Aristotle discusses here in the
categories is such but there are certain
qualities that are you know so specific
to something that you could say they're
close to it's s
or they're almost essential to it
they're not quite essential to it that's
that's a topic for another time
now Aristotle is going to run through in
the early part of this this long chapter
eight multiple ways and he's going to
distinguish he says for that we can talk
about something as having a quality and
here we're not just talking about
figures of speech we're talking about
making something like metaphysical
distinctions between different ways in
which something can be such-and-such can
have a quality and then we can speak
about it as having such a quality so the
first one that he talks about is habit
and disposition and like I was saying
this really does you know apply most of
human beings because if you look at the
the examples of habits that he gives he
talks about virtues and vices that is
determinate modes of goodness and
badness in a moral sense honor to
goodness coming from Agathis right and
kochia coming from Kakos bad vice
badness right so these are types of
habits Aristotle says hack says things
that are stable within ourselves and
we're going to talk more about this at
greater length in another video
dispositions are something that are not
quite as stable as habits we can talk
about somebody being disposed to do
something I am you know for example I
don't make a habit of it but I am
because I don't pay all that much
attention to what I'm doing I'm somewhat
disposed to getting chalk on my shirt
from rubbing up against the board right
and we'll talk about that more in
another video as I said actually for
each of these we will do that natural
capacity the word here
Dunamis phousi Cain this is something
that we have as part of our nature some
translations will talk about this as
being inborn
that's not that bad of a translation
Aristotle uses the example of somebody
having a natural talent for various
things like boxing for example or here
we go good boxers good runners he also
talks about some people being naturally
healthy having a good Constitution we
say or naturally disease naturally
sickly so natural capacities or in
capacities what would be an example of
an incapacity being sickly right being
clumsy could be an example of a natural
capital incapacity right because its
opposite would be I don't know something
like dexterous nosov zenus would be
something that a person has we could
also talk about mental capacities in
this this respect although it turns out
that in many respects those those are
quite malleable alright as even the
ancient Greeks knew what we do in terms
of habits really has a big impact on
what natural capacities or in capacities
develop into in concrete circumstances I
should mention as well going back to
habit and disposition that another thing
that Aristotle talks about as habit is
knowledge he conceives of knowledge when
we actually do have knowledge as opposed
to mere information or you know just
having a random experience when we
really know something really understand
it we have a firmly established
conception of it and perhaps what we
often talk about is skill sets within
our mind something that's not easily
eroded for think about for example
learning a language you don't
necessarily have to practice it every
single day to still have that habit in
your mind I'll give you another great
example of how these two might you know
sort of intersect think about musical
talents right if you learn an instrument
some people are
naturally better at learning instruments
some people have for example perfect
pitch which can be quite useful other
people may have other things they can
sort of visualize you know if you're
playing the guitar the keyboard it's
very useful to be able to visualize
music theory concepts in your your mind
even if you may not understand it as
music theory but then there's the actual
practicing and that's how you build your
capacity so for example I can
I haven't played bass guitar in any sort
of way for you know close to 20 years
but when I pick up my old bass that I
gave to my daughter some of the songs
and some of the scales and some of the
the you know the knot riffs but licks
and and bass fills that I learned way
back then that I acquired as a habit
come come naturally to me so you could
say you know music natural talent or
lack of talents right and then we can
talk about they kept it you know the
ability to play as being a kind of
knowledge a kind of habit that's been
developed then Aristotle talks about a
third type of quality this he devotes a
lot of discussion to so I'm only going
to go and scratch the surface here we
have when he calls passive qualities
pathetic i toyota case and this you this
is a bit of a misnomer in some respects
because he's talking about things that
can be for example perceived so when we
talk about taste right the bitterness of
coffee the fattiness of the the milk or
creamer that we add to it the sweetness
of the sugar that we sweeten it with all
of these sorts of things would be
passive qualities that is they can
produce a apophis affection or a
sensation in somebody else so those are
all quite important and then he also
talks about what's being translated
sometimes as affections or another
way of translating it would be the the
emotions you know when he talks about
for example a person who feels fear
turning white a person who feels shame
turning red those are those are
affections of the body he says there's
also affections in the same sense of the
soul the last one that he talks about is
figure or schema in Greek it's the word
that we get schematics from another
thing you could structure is another way
you could translate it and form or morph
a not not like a platonic form but
Aristotle's conception of form as it
exists in matter or perhaps in our minds
right so those are also qualities and he
gives example of something being
triangular right or if you think about
an example that Aristotle likes to use
in other places the bronze circle
alright the circularity of it is a a
form a schema of structure you know
another word we could use this pattern
it's pattern it's type right and so all
of these are qualities that something
can have the last thing that I want to
bring up in this particular discussion
is that he says that the names of
qualified things that is things to which
qualities are attributed are often
derived from qualities so for example we
can we can take the word grammar right
and then we can say grammatical meaning
somebody has learned grammar right and
then grammarian the person who has the
knowledge of grammar as a habit would be
derived from the quality of grammatical
which itself would be derived as well as
we we saw it an earlier example white
right whiteness you know we could talk
about flavor profiles is a great example
of this
you know when we class things together
oh yeah for example when we talk about
the sweet as an entire range of
different things
we're deriving that from the quality of
sweetness so there's a Aristotle also
says some things we don't actually have
in that sense we don't have names for
all of these but we could supply names
if we wanted to and you'll often see
Aristotle coming up with names so the
category of quality contains a lot of
different types and each of them
requires some discussion and Aristotle
does devote you know a good portion of
the categories that is chapter eight to
discussing precisely these four types